Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Colin Quinn.
You talk a lot about how
technology is affecting us,
and now technology is creeping
into things like the way we
communicate to each other.
-Sure.
-And the way we write
and make art, ChatGPT.
-Yeah.
A lot of people have been
talking about this.
It's AI, it can write.
We -- because you mentioned
technology.
We asked ChatGPT to write a
Colin Quinn stand-up routine.
-That's fine, but I don't
know why you had
to start by blaming me, because
you mentioned technology.
[ Laughter ]
Like, as if I demanded this.
You guys are blaming me
for my own demise.
Go ahead.
-You haven't seen it.
-Didn't see it.
-Alright.
You have not seen it.
This is very exciting
to see if it confuses you.
-Oh, I have to do it.
-You have to read it.
Alright.
Um, this is my stand-up act.
"Hey, folks,
welcome to the show.
Now, I've gotta say, things
getting pretty crazy out there.
I mean, you turn on the news,
it's like,
'What the hell is happening?'"
[ Laughter ]
-How are you feeling
about it so far?
-I'm feeling horrified.
"But, you know what?
I don't even bother watching
the news anymore.
I just go on social media
and read the comments.
That's where you really get
the real news.
You know, the news
that really matters."
I like to reiterate,
apparently.
-[ Laughs ]
You should feel good.
This is so bad,
you should feel good
about the fact that
you're outwriting
circles around this computer.
-Well, you know,
but it's kind of like getting
to an essence of me
that I'm not happy with.
[ Laughter ]
"Like, I can't believe this
country is going to hell."
I think I said that.
"And I'm moving to Canada."
That must be the big punch line.
"Why does everyone --
why does everyone hate us?
Then you get these politicians,
oh, boy, the politicians.
[ Laughter ]
"They're like the weather.
Nobody really likes them, but
you've got to deal with them.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what they say
about politicians?
they're like diapers,
they need to be changed often
for the same reason."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, that's more
than enough of that.
-That was great.
-I think you're good.
What I'm saying is
I think you're good.
-That was beautiful and
horrifying at the same time.
Can I have that for my show?
-Of course.
You can have it for later
tonight. Let's see how it goes.
But this goes to the questions
of authenticity,
and I think with AI
and with things like this,
people are worried about
will we be able
to recognize authenticity.
People claim they want
authenticity all the time,
but you don't think
that's the case.
-No, authenticity is the --
that's the one thing we don't.
We're trying to get away
from it.
Animals are authentic.
That's the whole point.
We're trying to get away from --
Like, you don't want --
everybody's like oh,
these politicians are fake.
Yeah, that's what we want --
a fake.
You don't want a real president.
You don't want somebody
coming out,
like a worried president, coming
out and being like,
"For state of the union,
oh God, oh God.
Oh, no. Putin is really
going to do it."
HE starts crying in the middle
of the thing.
You want a guy that comes out
and goes our
best days are ahead of us.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think of --
I mean, George Santos,
do you think he's inauthentic
or is he maybe
the most authentic politician?
-First of all, yeah.
I mean, he's social media, which
you can be whatever you decide
to be that day, everybody gets
to be whatever we want.
So he's like, hey, today
I'm this, today I'm that.
And -- but it is funny,
isn't it?
That you get -- that's not --
you have to resign.
Lying is not part of your job.
[ Laughter ]
Because they said things like,
"What if somebody lies?"
They're like, "Do you want
to really get rid of him?
I mean..."
-I was surprised to hear this,
that you were a huge
James Joyce fan,
and that James Joyce
actually inspired not, I guess,
the way you wrote.
But would you think the way
you wrote?
-Oh, the way I wrote too, yeah.
-Okay.
-When I started comedy,
I would --
First of all, before I started
comedy, not that I was
a pretentious guy, I'd walk
around with a copy of "Ulysses"
in my pocket, sit around to hope
people would notice "Ulysses."
-Pretty big book.
-Pretty big book,
but I always --
I always had a copy, you know?
But Joyce speaks,
Ulysses especially,
speaks in a run-on sentence.
So the whole book is like one --
there's no periods.
So when I started comedy, I was
like, I'm going to be like
the Irish, kind of, you know,
mavericks, cerebral.
Nobody was asking for this,
but just wait a second.
[ Laughter ]
There was no reason,
it was the mid '80s.
Now you say I want
to separate myself.
Back then you
didn't even have to,
but I chose my path.
So I go on stage
and just never even break,
and so there's no place
for people to laugh,
even if they had
chosen to laugh.
So I just kept talking,
and then eventually
if people don't laugh in
stand-up,
even if they're being amused, it
feels like a bomb to everybody.
I'd be getting mad at them
for not laughing,
even though there's no place
to get a laugh.
They'd be getting mean because
they're not getting
laughs at a comedy show.
It was very ugly few years.
[ Laughter ]
And to this day,
I still obviously have
an element of it
in my presentation.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know.
This is something
you discovered.
James Joyce was not just
a writer, he was a singer.
->> He was a second best singer
in all of Ireland.
-Who is the -- it's such
a funny title to be
the second best singer
in all of Ireland.
-I mean, it's great.
I guess he he was like --
he was like "The Banshees
of Inisherin."
-Yeah.
-I wasn't going to say
Martin McDonagh,
director reference either,
by the way.
Because that would have been
like, you know.
I don't know what.
Um, yeah.
He was a great singer,
and his wife wanted him
to be a singer, instead he
decided to write these books,
you know, these rambling books
that annoyed people.
-Is that how -- his rambling
books are annoying you?
-I mean, "Finnegans Wake,"
have you tried to read it?
I've tried to read it 30 times.
I've read books about
"Finnegans Wake"
to understand it, and those
books don't even understand it.
-How many -- So, okay, I've
tried dense books before,
and I will usually say my bail
point is 25, 30 pages.
Is that how far you've gotten
into before you like --
-No, no, I've read
"Finnegans Wake
and I've Joseph Campbell's book
on "Finnegans Wake,"
and he really -- you can tell --
Joseph Cambell's like a genius,
he has no idea about
what Finnegans --
I know more about it
than he did.
I'm reading this going,
"What's he talking about?"
I don't think he read it.
-Well, I think -- I think
everybody who watches this
is going to run out
and buy a "Finnegans Wake."
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
You guys, "Small talk," Lucille
Lortel Theater,
That's Colin Quinn,
we'll be right back
with Gabrielle union.